hi I didn't feel well and after when
they're making support & A panel long
since nvidia implications you should be
d id place one I think it's pretty clear
of that video if you have to stay away
clearly it's an abusive anyone you see
the North Africa I'm in the middle east
another part of the world something that
consideration it's also not something
that is one of your office companies and
brands as organization must learn how to
listen to our customers listen to the
person who is executed by a more effects
of this and not fine players always
doing the current age world marketing
techniques of trying to cells of the
property is that mean yes or no somebody
and then I have one more after so this
is a mountain and I think on the matter
of privacy very clearly it is a
challenge but I think we all agree that
it's something special it's more of a
sensitivity the West not so much peace
or academic education here that much
left over for and issues related to the
six yd a scare you where the internet
and this is in India basis for in
question over the next five or ten years
is like anything media once he reaches a
certain critical in basic effects how
much must take